thousands
are urging bezos to buy and eat the mona
lisa and finally use his money for good
bro bible okay why hasn't anyone ever
taken a buyer at the mona lisa jeff
bezos the world's wealthiest man can
afford to buy it and take a bite it's
time he started putting his money to
good use and doing good
doing things nobody else can the mona
lisa is a 518 year old
uh uh 518 years old that's a long time
to have existed without a single living
soul taking a bite out of the painting
bezos can afford to do that
anything he wants literally anything
that's the premise for this petition
that
uh has picked up thousands of signatures
over the weekend so why shouldn't bezos
with his fortune of 193 billion dollars
buy the painting and take a bite going
to space is stupid there's nothing in
space worth seeing but earth
and you can see earth from here you
could take a hot air balloon
really high if we wanted to according to
fox news an art expert
valued mona lisa at 60.9 billion dollars
last year well let me just let me let me
jump in here because i know you're not a
fan of space you have no interest of
going to space
i like space i just don't want to go in
it i have no problem with space it's
sort of like with pets with me i don't
dislike them i just don't want any all
right well you don't have to go
one percent chance so rather than taking
a bite out of the mona lisa by the way i
think this is obviously a
a humorous sort of uh joke of a story to
buy a 60 billion dollar painting and
take a bite here's a better idea it's an
onion story no i don't think so i think
it's
actually that that's not absurd that
they wanted to do this i think
like you talked about picture of the
young jeff bezos right
the young jeff bezos now the is 50
something years old wants to go to space
i think if you're going to do if you're
going to buy the mona lisa rather than
taking a bite out of the mona lisa which
is
just absurd on the face of it take the
mona lisa
to space with you let's say you spend a
quarter of your wealth yeah
now can you imagine who painted the mona
lisa leonardo da vinci yes
leonardo da vinci you know 500 something
years later your painting that you
painted
in italy right is now in space
looking down it's the one painting in
space that to me has a little more
brazing that would be actually kind of
cool you could get some good shots of
that
the mona lisa looking out the window
seeing her eyes out you know when you
have i've seen the mona lisa in person
it's a lot smaller than you would think
yeah it's not that way
you know i think the most interesting
aspect of this story is what the value
of the mona lisa would be
i think 61 billion is preposterous i
think that's ridiculous you wouldn't pay
for it
well i just don't think if let's throw
it out there in an open market and
here's what i think it would get i think
it would get
in the billions i think we had over a
billion i'm guessing one to two billion
somewhere in that range it would def
his most expensive painting that
leonardo da vinci ever had was 450
million
okay it was uh uh prince bhatter bin
abdullah of saudi arabia bought it for
450 million um
so that's the most expensive painting
that was the painting it was the
salvador mundi okay and it was jesus in
a blue dress
okay kind of an odd one where his
fingers were making the sign of the
cross can you pull that up so that went
for 450 million
billion and by the way the mona lisa is
owned by the french government it's
owned by the city
it's in the louvre yeah there it is that
thing went for 450 million
saudi prince is that crazy the mona lisa
is worth 60 billion no no i don't
believe it is that's what that's what a
franchise
well that's what a french government
official said and the french government
owns the mona lisa
here here's a here's the most ironic
part of that i think a five billion
dollar offer would get it
here's the most ironic part of this so
let's say it was valued at 60 billion
60 billion do you know that where that
would put mona lisa
in the world's wealthiest people it
would be number 20 and it would bump
jeff bezos ex-wife mackenzie scott
from the top 20.
he might do it just to say mackenzie
you're out mona lisa
my new baby tink is worth more than jeff
bezos's ex-wife
same amount but she they she's a little
bit i think she's 59 and this is such a
billion dollars more yeah worth a
billion dollars more than it is there
okay so take the take the mona lisa to
the space rather than take a bite out of
the
mona lisa so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye